-Our first guest
is an EGOT-winning performer
who once again
has her holiday sweater line --
look at these --
available at Nordstrom.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She also produces and stars
in the new film, "Till,"
which is in theaters right now.
Please welcome our pal,
Whoopi Goldberg,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Over my head ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, but it sure feels nice ♪
♪ Over my head ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, but it sure feels nice ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, that's
what I'm talking about.
Now, come on, now.
Thank you, thank you, Whoopi.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
-Can I give you this you?
-Yeah, I want some of that.
-Hey, guys.
Hey, y'all.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
Whoo!
You are the best guest.
Come on, you bring gifts.
-I like bringing gifts.
-You bring gifts,
you bring joy,
you bring Prosecco?
-Yes.
-What are we doing?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ooh-la-la.
-Yes.
Prosecco is --
Is this because --
I know -- I heard you're
spending time in Italy.
-Yes.
-Did you buy a place in Italy?
-I might have.
[ Laughter ]
I might have.
But this is all about
not marrying well.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that right?
-Because when you don't
marry well,
you have to keep working.
-Yeah, okay.
Oh, I understand.
Ah.
I understand.
-So, I thought Prosecco
would work well for me.
-Oh, I love Prosecco.
And you actually have
a little sip of it --
cheers -- for me.
-Yes, please.
-And The Roots -- Prosecco.
Cheers, everybody.
-Ahh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I hope it's cold.
-Ooh!
Yummy!
-Is it cold?
-It's perfectly cold.
-Okay.
-Perfectly chilled.
Whoopi Prosecco, I love it.
And what was the bread
you brought?
You always bring us some
nice goods, baked goods.
-Pane-- Panettone.
-Yes.
-it's Christmas bread.
-It is!
You did!
You brought the Christmas
holiday spirit with you!
-I did. I brought the holiday.
And the Hanukkah.
-I brought the Hanukkah.
-You brought the Hanukkah.
You brought the Christmas.
You brought 'em both.
Look at this.
These are some
new sweaters you got.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
C is for Christmas.
C is for Chanukah.
C is for --
I love --
-And there
are red balls everywhere.
-Yeah, and there are red --
[ Laughter ]
Exactly.
There are red balls everywhere.
-You know.
-I love that you do this.
And I love --
Gosh, were we here
the first time
when you started doing this?
-Yeah.
-Is that right?
-I brought the first ones
to you.
-Yeah, I love these.
Thank you
for doing it every year.
You have a new edition to these.
They're available at Nordstrom.
But you have a new edition...
-Yes, I do.
-...to bring the spirit in.
And we have a couple models
that are gonna come out
and model for us right now.
-Oh, fantastic.
-Here they are with some new
Whoopi's holiday sweaters.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-[ Laughs ]
Hello!
Hi, baby.
Hi.
Ooh!
Ooh, ooh!
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, you got --
You got a feisty one.
-Hoo!
-You got a feisty one there.
[ Laughter ]
-You are too cute.
-Mine doesn't care about me
at all.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a puppy.
This is --
This is an older dog.
[ Laughter ]
She might not be older.
Well, a little bit.
-You got some love.
-She's big.
But she looks good in a sweater.
[ Laughter ]
-Look at -- Come on.
Look at this.
And it's got a little --
-It's got a hoodie.
It's got a hoodie.
She's got a hoodie, too.
[ Laughter ]
-She's not happy about it.
-Oh, it's cute, though.
-She don't like the hoodie.
She's like,
"What the hell, Whoopi?
What the hell?!"
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if you should
give me both of them.
-Yeah, I think you got it.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You gotta have both puppies.
Come on, Whoopi.
-All right. Well, if he starts
sniffing his butt,
I don't know
what I'm gonna do.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, I love you, too.
-This one loves you, too.
Oh, my --
Whoopi, you're getting the love
from the pups.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yes.
-Are you a dog lover?
-I am a dog lover,
but I have cats.
-Well, I hope you are.
I should've asked that earlier.
[ Laughter ]
I should've asked that before
they were licking your face off.
Oh.
Look at this.
He loves you.
-Oh, I'm just gonna give you --
Oh, my goodness.
-I got nothing from that puppy.
Get ov-- Get over here.
Come here.
Give me this one, yeah.
-Ooh, child, that's a big --
-Wow.
Pbht!
-This is not a puppy at all.
Hi.
-That is a puppy.
-That's what I'm -- pbht!
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
Pbht!
That's what I wanted.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know.
-Come here.
I didn't want you doing anything
on the sweater.
Oh, geez.
-Had a little bit of doggy poo.
But that's all right.
That's all right.
I've got a little something,
too.
-All right, perfect.
Pfft!
-Aww.
-All right.
Can we take our models?
Can someone take our --
Oh.
You're hopping up here again?
Here you go.
We can have our models
taken away.
-Thank you.
-But thank you for being here.
-Wonderful.
-You can clap, sure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Oof. That was --
-Wow.
-Oh, but it's
kind of late for this.
[ Laughter ]
-That one got sloppy,
that first one.
[ Laughter ]
I think that first one
had a little Prosecco
before it came out.
-I think so.
I think so.
-Yeah, had a little Prosecco,
that first one.
-Had a little wine
on its breath.
-Yeah, it did have a little --
[ Laughs ]
I love that.
Thank you
for having them out here.
Thanks for always coming.
And congrats on the sweaters.
You can get them
right now at Nordstrom,
ladies and gentlemen.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I have questions to ask you.
-Okay.
-We've talked about this
on the show -- "Sister Act 3."
The people have spoken.
We want it.
-Yeah.
-And you said,
"They're gonna get it."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-And we're going to get it.
-The script came in yesterday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
Good?
-I really like it.
You know, but it has a whole
lot of adults to go through.
So if they don't get in its way,
it could actually
be pretty good.
And I'm just saying, you know --
Did you ever see --
what was it --
"Batman," the TV show?
-Yes.
-Remember when Batman and Robin
would be going up
the side of the wall?
-Yes.
-And suddenly a window
would open, and somebody would
stick their head out?
-Yeah.
-Would you stick your head out
if we made a space for you
to just come and do it
for, like, a day?
-Yes! Are you kidding me?
-No.
-To be in "Sister Act 3"?
-Yeah.
-Of course I would do that!
I would do anything for you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'd do anything -- I love you!
I would do anything for that.
-Thank you.
-I love --
I just love
even the story behind it, too,
because you pitched a sequel.
And then, they were like --
the studio were like,
"Maybe not."
And then just
the people took over.
-And then people went berserk,
and I thank you so much.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you do it.
-That's how you do it.
Let's talk about your new film,
"Till."
-"Till," yeah.
You produced this.
You star in this.
Man, oh, man,
the reviews are unbelievable.
98% on Rotten Tomatoes.
-Right.
And this is, uh --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's something
you've been working on.
-We've been trying
to get this made,
and the gentleman who really
was at the forefront of this,
his name is Keith Beauchamp.
And he knew Mamie Till Mobley,
and he had always hoped
we could get it done
before she passed.
But we weren't able to do it.
But the movie is so great.
And I just want to say
to everybody,
don't be afraid to go see it.
There's no --
You will understand that
the violence isn't there.
Because we don't need
to tell you what happened.
You know what happened.
But what you're seeing is a
relationship between a mother
who decides that the world needs
to see what was done to her son.
And it's the perspective
between a mother and a son.
And we all know mothers,
and we all know sons.
So, please, if you have
11-year-olds, 12-year-olds,
it's good for them
because it's part of
the history of the country.
We can't pretend
it didn't happen. It did.
But what it did was,
it began a movement
like no other that we've seen.
So please go see it.
And the woman that plays
Mrs. Mobley
just won the Gotham Award
for Best Actress.
Her name is Danielle Deadwyler.
-She was phenomenal.
-She is --
I've never
seen a performance like this.
She is --
It's just --
It's the best thing I think
I've ever seen from an actor.
-Yeah.
-It's powerful.
It's amazing.
And you got to be in it
with her.
-Yes.
-Were you always
supposed to be in it?
I think you were just
producing it.
-This is how long ago
we started this.
When we started talking about
doing it and helping Keith,
Barbara Broccoli and Fred Zollo,
who did "Mississippi Burning"
and all these other films.
And so we tried, I think,
for the last 12 years
to get it done.
And everybody kept saying,
"No, nobody wants to see this.
They know this.
Nobody wants --"
And we got really lucky.
And then we,
got a brilliant director,
who did such an amazing job...
-Had a vision.
-...at making this family
and this incident
part of your family.
So that you recognize
that this kind of --
What is it called? --
incipient -- this racism.
When you see it
in its full-blown, ugly face,
as we show you in the film,
what it does to people.
When you see it like that,
you begin to recognize
that it could happen
to any of us.
That this could happen
to any of us at any time.
So please, do me a favor.
This --
The performances are so good
that, I tell you,
you will not be angry at me.
-Yeah.
-You won't be pissed at me
when you see this.
-No, no.
-It's a fabulous film.
-We love you, bud.
I'm so happy you did this.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Whoopi Goldberg
in "Till."
Take a look at this.
-We've never been apart
this long.
-He's just going
to see his cousins.
It's not a bad thing for him
to know where he come from.
-Chicago is all
he needs to know.
I don't want him seeing himself
the way those people
are seen down there.
-Those people like me?
-Even you left Mississippi,
Mama.
-Mamie, Bo is growing up.
You gonna have to let him go.
All right, I know that face.
That is the face of
"Mama, mind your business
and go home."
Where's my pocketbook?
-Mm-hmm.
-Come on.
That's Whoopi Goldberg.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Till" is in theaters right now,
everyone.
Please go see this film.